my name is Samuel Leeds and on this
video I need to share these five things
these are the five things that I learned
about and was really impacted by still
Vestas alone he's a top guy and the
pleasure of meeting him in person I need
to share these five things with you stay
tuned
[Music]
point one don't play the victim don't
play the victim I mean so many people
who say oh because of my background
because this happened to me it's
different for me yada-yada-yada they
suffer from excuse itis Sylvester
Stallone
he has got not a great background not a
great background I didn't know that
about him he was bullied at school he
was very very skinny
he's from quite an unloved family as he
said yeah he had to make a choice is he
gonna let that affect his the way his
future is because of his past or is he
gonna say you know what my past will not
define my future as he says it it's not
about how hard you get hit but about how
hard you can get hit and keep standing
and keep walking that's what winning is
so that's it number one do not play the
victim
regardless away from being Victoire look
forward next point to have dogged
persistence have dogged persistence
never give up sylvester stallone when he
grew up as i said before not from a
privileged background at all
he wrote the rocky script and he was
going around pushing down people's
throats and the script finally was
accepted and they offered to pay him a
large amount of money for the script but
they said that they didn't want him to
act in it
but he could have very easily taken the
money it would have changed his life or
at least changed his year but because of
his dogged persistence
he's an all-or-nothing guy he said no if
you want the script that's fine but it
comes with me and his persistence and
his dogged determination he kept
fighting he kept pushing they accepted
it they accepted him and the script
boom 29 years old he went from broke to
oscar-winning millionaire everyone knew
who he was absolutely peaked when you
have dogged persistence sometimes you
just fail fail fail fail and then
suddenly like the bamboo tree shoot up
it looks like over nowhere it looks like
I don't know it people say wow that was
like an overnight success but
you want to have an overnight success
he's got to always come beforehand
dogged persistence and determination
next point three have a role model you
need a role model you need someone that
you can look up to aspire to be like his
first role model he shared the story was
actually he went to the cinema and he
watched the movie Hercules and at the
time he was a very skinny teenager he
got picked on he didn't have a lot of
self-worth he saw the movie Hercules at
the cinemas and he was like I want to be
like that guy I wanted to be Britt I
want to be strong I don't want anyone to
mess with me that's my inspiration
that's and Hercules almost became a role
model and then he started working out he
became a winner because he had some
inspiration so I always say don't look
up to anyone but look into but you've
got to have people around you for
inspiration for success because if
you're the smartest person in the room
it's you're the most successful person
in the room you're in the wrong room so
find role models find mentors who are
more successful than you are that you
can aspire to be like go get yourself
some role models point number four make
mistakes make mistakes
why because mistakes are okay still mr.
Sloane says that he loves making
mistakes because every time he messes it
up he learns from it and he's one step
closer to succeeding so instead of
seeing it as a mistake as a problem or a
bad thing or a failure see it as a real
life first-hand lesson of how not to do
it next time and that's kind of his life
you know he's this very very successful
man very famous very good at what he
does and he says that he's just
continually made mistakes and failed his
way into success in the movie scenes
he'll just shoot a movie he'll fail it
he'll fail it he'll fail it he'll do it
so don't be scared to make a mistake
some people's problem is that they don't
want to do something and then mess it up
and look stupid but unless you're
prepared to make mistakes and expect
things to go wrong
then you're probably not going to see
things go right at least to the amount
that you want so make mistakes mistakes
are okay and we learn from them I always
say this write a book filled with your
mistakes so that was really powerful and
lastly 0.5 and this one is my favorite
this one is just incredible and now is
this be creative Sylvester Stallone is
the
turning a negative into a positive
turning a bad situation into a good one
flipping the cards and he does this in
so many ways I'll show a couple one is
his speech like he speaks like a drunk
person he's got this slur to his voice
and if he wants to be a movie star and a
communicator and I mean you could say
well that's her that's a bad thing but
it's part of his brand and people love
him for it now so rather than being
insecure and thinking or you know I
speak a bit funny he turns into a good
thing I mean he he said that at least I
speak more clearly than Arnold
Schwarzenegger which was kind of funny
they have a lot of rivalry but he's
flipped the cards next is when he when
he did his first couple of Rockies the
producer said to him they said steel
Vestas alone is dead Rocky is dead we
need it's time to move on it's buried
it's dead it's finished no one cares
anymore and instead of thinking our case
dead you know that's it it's finished
and then giving up he flipped the cards
and he was creative what he did was he
then came back and did the Rocky Balboa
and the whole theme was Rocky is dead so
he turned what someone said to him is a
real negative into that might be a good
idea for a film and and the whole film
about how you know what being a past it
box so what was that was actually really
entertaining and it was a big hit so he
turned the biggest negative ever which
is you're dead your careers dead which
is exactly what they said to him
word-for-word he turned that into a
positive
into a positive made a massive hit he's
now 72 years old I was with him on his
birthday and he's still like a walking
legend so that's five things that I
learned from Rocky I hope you found that
inspiring so go kick some butt please
comment on your thoughts below subscribe
like share stay tuned I'll see you next
time thank you so much for watching if
you benefited on that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time